The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today, I'd
like to wrap together
and summarize everything that
we have been doing the last 10,
12 lectures.
So the idea started by saying
that you take something
like a magnet, you
change its temperature.
You go from one phase
that is paramagnet
at some critical temperature
Tc to some other phase that
is a ferromagnet.
Naturally, the
direction of magnetism
depends whether you put on a
magnetic field and went to 0.
So there's a lot of
these transitions
that involve ferromagnet.
There were a set of other
transitions that involved,
for example, superfluids
or superconductivity.
And the most common
example of phase
transition being
liquid gas, which
has a coexistence line
that also terminates
at the critical point.
So you have to turn
it around a little bit
to get a coexistence
line like this.
Fine.
So there are phase transitions.
The interesting thing was that
when people did successively
better and better
experiments, they
found that the singularities
in the vicinity
of these critical
points are universal.
That is, it doesn't matter
whether you have iron, nickel,
or some other thing that is
undergoing ferromagnetism.
You can characterize the
divergence of the heat capacity
to an exponent alpha, which
ferromagnets is minus 0.12.
For superfluids, we said
that people even take things
on satellites to calculate
this exponent to much
higher accuracy than
I have indicated.
For the case of liquid gas,
there is a true divergence
and the exponent is around 0.11.
There are a whole set
of other exponents
that I also mentioned.
There is the exponent beta for
how the magnetization vanishes.
And the values here
were 0.37, 0.35, 0.33.
There is the divergence of
the susceptibility gamma that
is characterized
through exponents
that are 1.39, 1.32, 1.24.
And there is a divergence
of the correlation length
characterized by exponents
[INAUDIBLE] 0.71, 0.67, 0.63.
So there is this
table of pure numbers
that don't depend on the
property of the material
that you are looking at.
And the fact that you don't
have this material dependence
suggests that these pure
numbers are some characteristics
of the collective
behavior that gives rise
to what's happening at
this critical point.
And we should be able to
devise some kind of a theory
to understand
that, maybe extract
these nice, pure numbers,
which are certainly embedded
in the physics of the problem
that we are looking at.
So the first idea that
we explored conceptually
due to lambda probably,
probably others,
is that we should construct
the statistical field.
That is, what is
happening is irrespective
of whether we are dealing with
nickel or iron, et cetera.
So the properties of
the microscopic elements
should disappear
and we should be
focusing on the quantity that is
undergoing a phase transition.
And that quantity, we said, is
some kind of a magnetization.
And what distinguishes
the different systems is
that for ferromagnet,
it's certainly
a three-component system.
But in general, for superfluid
we would have a phase.
And that's a
two-component object,
so we introduced
this parameter n
that characterized the symmetry
of the order parameter.
And in the same way,
we said let's look
at things that are
embedded in space.
That is, in general,
d dimensional.
So our specification of
the statistical field
was on the basis
of these things.
And the idea of lambda was
to construct a probability
for this field,
configurations across space.
Once we had that, we could
calculate a partition function,
let's say, by integrating
over all configurations
of this field of some
kind of a weight.
And we constructed the weight.
We wrote something as beta
H was an integral d dx.
And then we put a whole
bunch of things in here.
We said we could have something
like t over 2m squared.
We had gradient of m squared.
Potentially, we could
have higher derivatives
staying at the
order of m squared.
And so this list
of things that I
could put that are all order of
m squared is quite extensive.
Then I could have things
that are fourth order,
like u m to the fourth.
And we saw that when we
performed this renormalization
group last time around, that a
term that we typically had not
paid attention to was generated.
Something that was,
again, order of m
to the fourth, but had
a structure maybe like m
squared gradient of m
squared, or some other form
of the two-derivative operator.
This is OK.
There could be other
types of things
that have four m's in it.
And you could have something
that is m to the sixth, m
to the eighth, et cetera.
So the idea of lambda was to
include all kinds of terms
that you can put.
But actually, we have
already constrained terms.
So the idea of
lambda is all terms
consistent with some
constraints that you put.
What are the
constraint that we put?
We put locality in that we wrote
this as an integral over x.
We considered symmetry.
So if I am at the 0
field limit, I only
have terms that are proportional
to m squared, rotationally
symmetric.
And there is something
else that is implicit,
which is analyticity.
What do I mean?
I mean that there is,
in some sense here,
a space of parameters
composed of all
of these coefficients--
t, k, u, v.
And these are
supposed to represent
what is happening to my
system that I have in mind
as I change the temperature.
And so in principle, if I
do some averaging procedure
and arrive at this description,
all of these parameters
presumably will be
functions of temperature.
And the statement
is that the process
of coarse gaining the
degrees of freedom
and averaging to arrive
at this description
and the corresponding
parameters involves
finite number of
degrees of freedom.
And adding and
integrating finite numbers
of degrees of freedom can only
lead to analytical functions.
So the statement here is
that this set of parameters
are analytical functions.
So given this
construction by lambda,
we should be able to figure
out if this is correct,
what is happening and where
these numbers come from.
So what did we attempt?
The first thing
that we attempted
was to do saddle point.
And we saw that
doing so just looking
at the most probable state
fails because fluctuations
were important.
We tried to break
the Hamiltonian
into a part that was
quadratic and Gaussian.
And we could calculate
everything about it,
and then treating everybody
else as a perturbation.
And when we
attempted to do that,
we found that
perturbation theory
failed below four dimensions.
So at this stage, it
was kind of an impasse
in that as far as
physics is concerned,
we feel that this thing
captures all of the properties
that you need in
order to somehow
be able to explain
those phenomena.
Yet, we don't have
the mathematical power
to carry out the integrations
that are implicit in this.
So then the idea was, can
we go around it somehow?
And so the next set of
things that we introduced
were basically
versions of scaling.
And quite a few
statistical physicists
were involved with that.
Names such as [INAUDIBLE],
Fisher, and number of others.
And the idea is that
if we also consider,
let's say, introducing a
magnetic field direction here
and look at the singularities
in the plane that involves
those two that is necessary
to also characterize
some of these other
things such as gamma,
then you have a singular
part for the free energy that
is a function of how
far you go away from Tc.
So this t now stands
for T minus Tc.
And how far you go along the
direction that breaks symmetry.
And the statement was
that all of the results
were consistent with the form
that depended on really two
exponents that could
be bonded together
into the behavior
of the singular
part of the free
energy or the singular
part of the
correlation function.
And essentially, this
approach immediately
leads to exponent identities.
And these exponent identities
we can go back and look
at the table of numbers
that we have up there.
And we see that they
are correct and valid.
But well, what are the
two primary exponents?
How can we obtain them?
Well, going and looking at this
scaling behavior a little bit
further, one could trace back to
some kind of a self-similarity
that should exist right
at the critical point.
That is, the
correlation functions,
et cetera at the
critical point should
have this kind of
scaling variance.
And then the question
is, can we somehow manage
to use that property,
that looking at things
at different scales at
the critical points,
should give you the
same thing to divine
what these exponents are.
So the next stage
in this progression
was the work of Kadanoff in
introducing the idea of RG.
And the idea of RG was to
basically average things
further.
Here, implicit in
the calculation
that we had was some kind of a
short distance [INAUDIBLE] a.
And if we average
between a and b a,
then presumably these parameters
mu would change to something
else-- mu prime--
that correspond
to rescaling by a factor of b.
And these mu primes
would be a function
of the original set
of parameters mu.
And then Kadanoff's idea was
that the scaling variant points
would correspond to the points
where you have no changed.
And that if you then
deviated from that point,
you would have some
characteristic scale
in the problem.
And you could capture
what was happening
by looking at essentially how
the changes, delta mu prime,
were related to the
changes delta mu.
So essentially, linearizing
these relationships.
So there would be some kind of
a linearized transformation.
And then the eigenvalues
of this transformation
would determine how many
relevant quantities you should
have.
Now, the physics, the entire
physics of the process,
then comes into play here.
That the experiments
tell us that you can,
let's say, take superfluid and
it has this phase transition.
You change the pressure of
it, it still has that phase
transition-- slightly
different temperature,
but it's the same
phase transition.
You can add some
impurities to it
as you did in one
of the problems.
You still have the
phase transition.
So basically, the existence
of a phase transition
as a function of one parameter
that is temperature-like
is pretty robust.
And if we think about that in
the language of fixed point,
it meant that along
the symmetry direction,
there should be only
one relevant eigenvalue.
So this construction
that Kadanoff proposed
is nice and fine, but
one has to demonstrate
that, indeed, this infinite
number of parameters
can be boiled down
to a fixed point.
And that fixed point has
only one relevant direction.
So the next step
in this progression
was Wilson who did perturbative
version of this procedure.
So the idea was that we can
certainly solve beta H0.
And beta H0 is really a bunch
of Gaussian independent modes
as long as we look at
things in Fourier space.
So in Fourier space,
we have a bunch
of modes that exist over
some [INAUDIBLE] zone.
And as long as we are looking
at some set of wavelengths
and no fluctuation shorter
than that wavelength has been
allowed, there is
a maximum to here.
And the procedure of
averaging and increasing
this minimum wavelength
then corresponds
to integrating out modes that
are sitting outside lambda
over v and keeping modes
that we call m tilde that
live within 0 to lambda over p.
And if we integrate
these modes--
so if I rewrite this integration
as an integration over Fourier
modes, do this
decomposition, et cetera--
what I find is that
my-- after I integrate.
So step 1, I do a
coarse graining.
I find a Hamiltonian
that governs
the coarse-grained modes.
Well, if I integrate
out the sigma modes
and treat them as
Gaussians, then there
will be a contribution to
the free energy trivially
from those modes proportional
to volume, presumably.
Since these modes
and these modes
don't couple at the Gaussian
level, at the Gaussian level
we also have beta H0 acting on
these modes that I have kept.
And the hard part is, of
course, the interaction
between these
types of modes that
are governed by all of
these non-linearities
that we have over here.
And we kind of can formally
write that as minus log of e
to the minus u that depends
on m tilde and sigma
when I integrate out
in the Gaussian weight
the modes that are
the sigma parameters.
So that's formally correct.
This is some complicated
function of m tilde
after I get rid of
the sigma variables.
But presumably, if I
were to expand and write
this in powers of m tilde
and powers of gradient,
it will reproduce back
the original series.
Because I said that the original
series includes everything
that could possibly
be generated.
This is presumably, after
I do all of these things,
still consistent with
symmetries and so will
generate those kinds of terms.
But of course to
evaluate it, then we
have to do perturbation.
And so we can start expanding
this in powers of u.
And the first term
would be u, assuming
that u is a small quantity.
Then minus 1/2 u squared minus
u average squared and so forth.
And of course, this RG
has two other steps.
After I have
performed this step,
I have to do rescaling,
which in Fourier space
means I blow up q.
So q I will replace
with b inverse q prime.
And renormalize, which
meant that in Fourier space
I replace m with z m prime.
So after I do these
procedures, what do I find?
I find that to
whatever order I go,
I start with some
original Hamiltonian
that includes all terms
consistent with symmetries.
And I generate a new
log of probability.
It's not really a Hamiltonian.
It's the kind of
effective free energy.
It's the log of the probability
of these configurations.
So now I should be able to
read this transformation of how
I go from mu to mu prime.
So let's go through
this list and do it.
So t prime is something
that in Fourier space
went with one
integration over q.
So I got b to the minus d.
There's two factors
of m, so it's
a z square type of contribution.
And at the 0 order
from here, I have my t.
And then when I did the
average, from the average
of u I got a contribution
that was proportional to u.
There was a degeneracy of 4.
There were two kinds of diagrams
that were contributing to it,
and then I had the integral
from lambda over b to lambda,
d dk 2 pi to the d 1 over
t plus t plus k k squared.
And just to remind you
the kind of diagrams
that were contributing
to this, one of them
was something like
this and the other one
was something like this.
This one that had a closed
loop gave me the factor of n
and the other gave me
what was eventually
the eighth that I
have observed here.
So this is what we
found at order of u.
We went on and
calculated the u squared.
And the u squared will give
me another contribution.
There is a coefficient out here
that also similarly involves
integrals.
The integrals will depend on t.
They will depend on k.
They will depend on this
lambda that I'm integrating.
They will depend
on t, et cetera.
So there is some function here.
And we argued last time that
we don't need to evaluate it,
but let's write it down.
And let's make sure that
it doesn't contribute.
But this is only looking
at the effect of this u.
And I know that I have
all of these other terms.
So presumably, I
will get something
that will be of the order
of, let's say, v squared uv.
I will certainly get something
that is of the order of u6.
If I think of u6 as something
that has six legs associated
with it, I can
certainly join two
of these legs, two of these
legs and have something
that is two legs leftover, just
as I did getting from the u4 m
to the 4 2m squared.
I certainly can do that.
So there is all kinds of higher
order terms here in principle
that we have to keep track of.
Now, the next term in
the series is the k.
Compared to the t-terms, it
had two additional factor
of gradients.
When we do everything, it turns
out that it will be minus 2
because of the two gradients
that became q squared.
It's still second order
in m, so I would get this.
And then I start with k.
Now, the interesting
and important thing
is that when we do the
calculation at order of u,
we don't get any
correction to k.
The only diagrams that
could have contributed to k
were diagrams of this variety.
But diagrams of
this variety, we saw
that when I performed those
integrals the result just
doesn't depend on q.
It only corrected
the constant term
that is proportional
to t squared.
But that structure
will not preserve.
If I go to order
of u squared, there
will be some kind
of a correction that
is order of u squared.
And we kind of had in the
table in the table of 6
by 6 things that I
had a diagram that
gives contribution such as this.
That, in fact, look
something like this.
So basically, this is
a four-point vertex,
a four-point vertex.
I joined them.
I make these kinds
of calculation.
Now, once you do
that, you'll find
that the difference
between this diagram
and let's say that diagram
is that the momentum that
goes in here, q, will have
to just go through here
and there is no influence
on it on the momentum
that I'm integrating.
Whereas, if you look
at this diagram,
you will find that it
is possible to have
a momentum that going in here
and gets a contribution over
here.
And so the calculation, if I
were to do at higher order,
will have in the
denominator a product of two
of these factors,
but one of them
will explicitly depend on q.
And if I expanded
in powers of q,
I will get a correction
that will appear here.
It will not change
our life as we
will see what it's good
to know that it is there.
And there be higher-order
corrections here, too.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are the
functions a1 and a2
just labeled as such to
make our lives easier
or because they don't have any
sort of universality with them?
PROFESSOR: Both.
They don't carry at this
order in the expansion
any information for
what we will need,
but I have to show
it to you explicitly.
So right now, I keep
them as placeholders.
If, at the end of
the day, we find
that our answers will
depend on these quantities,
then we have to go back
and calculate them.
But ultimately, the reason
that we won't need them
is what I described last time.
That we will calculate
exponents only to lowest order
in 4 minus epsilon-- 4
minus d, which is epsilon.
And that all of these
u's at the fixed point
will be of the order of epsilon.
So both of these
terms are terms that
are order of epsilon
squared and will
be ignorable at
level of epsilon.
But so far I haven't talked
anything about epsilon,
so I may as well keep it.
And similarly, l prime
would be something
that goes with q
to the fourth if I
were to Fourier transform it.
So this would be b
to the d minus 4.
It is still z squared.
It will be proportional to l.
It will have exactly these
kinds of corrections also.
And I can keep going with the
list of all second-order terms.
Now, then we got to u prime.
u prime was a fourth
order, fourth power of m.
So it carried z to the fourth.
It involved three
derivatives in q space,
so it gave me b to the minus 3d.
And then to the lowest order
when I did the expansion
from u, one of the
terms that I got
was the original
potential evaluated
for m tilde rather
than the original m.
So I always will get this term.
And then I noticed that when
I go and calculate things
at second order--
and we explicitly
did that-- we got a
term that was minus 4 u
squared n plus 8 integral
lambda over b to lambda
d dk 2 pi to the d 1
over t plus k k squared.
And presumably, these
series also continue.
The whole thing squared.
It was a squared propagator
that was appearing over here.
And again, reminding
you that these
came from diagrams that were--
some of it was like this.
There was a loop that
gave us the factor of n.
And then there were things
like this one or this one.
Yeah.
And those gave out this huge
number compared to this.
Now, if I had included this
term that is proportional to v,
presumably I would
have gotten corrections
that are order of uv.
If I go to higher
orders, I will certainly
get things that are
of the order of u6.
I will certainly get things
that are of the order of u cubed
and so forth.
So there is a whole
bunch of corrections
that in principle,
if I am supposed
to include everything and
keep track of everything,
I should include.
Now, the v itself, v prime,
has two additional derivatives
with respect to u.
So it will be b to
the minus 3d minus 2.
It's a z to the
fourth type of term.
It is v, and then it will
certainly get corrections at,
say, at order of
uv and so forth.
And what else did I
write down in the series?
I can write as many as we
like. u prime to the 6.
This is something that
goes with 6 powers of z
and will have 5 derivatives.
Sorry, 5 integrations in q.
So it will give me
b to the minus 5d.
And again, presumably I
will have u6 minus order
of something like u squared
v and all kinds of things.
All right.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in the calculation
of terms like k prime and l
prime, you have factors
like b minus d minus 2.
Is it minus 2 or plus 2?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So these came from Fourier
transforming this entity.
When I Fourier transform,
I get integral dd q.
I will have t plus
k q squared plus l q
to the fourth, et cetera.
And my task is that
whenever I see q,
I replace it with
p inverse q prime.
So this would be
b to the minus d.
This would be b to the minus 2.
This would be b to the minus 4.
So that's how it comes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Anything else?
OK.
So then we had to choose
what this factor of z is.
And we said, let's
choose it such
that k prime is the same as k.
But k prime over k we can see
is z squared b to the minus
d minus 2.
If I divide through by
this k, then I will get 1,
and then something here
which is order of u squared.
Now, we will justify later
why u in order to be small
so that I can make
a construction that
is perturbative in u will
be of the order of epsilon.
But in any case, if I
want to in some sense
keep the lowest order
in u, at this order
I am justified to
get rid of this term.
And when I do that
to this order,
I will find that z is b
to the 1 plus d over 2.
And probably in
principle, corrections
that will be of the order of
this epsilon to the squared.
So I do that choice.
Secondly, I'll make my
b to be infinitesimal.
And so that means that
mu prime at scale b,
the set of parameters--
each parameter
would be basically mu plus
a small shift d mu by dl.
And then I can recast
these jumps by factors of b
that I have up there
to flow equations.
And so what do I get?
For the first one,
we got dt by dl.
And I had chosen z squared to
be b to the minus d minus 2.
So compared to the
original one, it's
just two more factors of b.
Two more factors of
b will give me 2t.
And then I will have to deal
with that integration evaluated
when b is very
small, which means
that I have to just
evaluate it on the shell.
So I will have 4u n plus 2
kd lambda to the d divided
by t plus k lambda squared
plus higher-orders terms
in this propagator.
And then I will
have, presumably,
some a1-looking
quantity, but evaluated
on the shell that
depends on u squared,
and then I will have
higher-order terms.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm kind
of curious on why
we choose k equals
k prime instead
of the constant in front of any
of the other gradient terms.
Why is k equals k prime better
than l equals l prime or--
PROFESSOR: OK.
We discussed this in the
context of the Gaussian model.
So what we saw for
the Gaussian model is
that if I choose
l prime to be l,
then I will have k
prime being b squared k
and t prime will be
b to the fourth t.
So I will have two
relevant directions.
So I want to have, in some
sense, the minimal levels
of direction guided by
the experimental fact
that you do whatever you
like and you see the phase
transition, except that you
have to change one parameter.
There could be something else.
There could very well--
somebody comes to me later
and describes some kind
of a phase transition
that requires two
relevant directions.
And the physics of it may guide
me to make the other choice.
But for the problem that
I'm telling you right now,
the physics guides me
to make this choice.
There is no equation
for k because we already
set that to be 0.
Let's write the equation for u.
So four u, z to the
fourth becomes 4 plus 2d.
And then minus 3d
becomes 4 minus d u.
And then the next
order term becomes
minus 4 u squared n plus 8 kd
lambda to the d t plus k lambda
squared and so
fourth squared when
I evaluate that
integral on the shell.
And then I will have
higher-order terms.
So this is where this idea
of making an expansion
in dimensions come into play.
Because we want to have
these sets of equations
somehow under control, we
need to have a small parameter
in which we are
making an expansion.
And ultimately, we will be
looking at the fixed point.
And the fixed point
occurs at u star.
That is, of the
order of 4 minus d.
Otherwise, there is no
small control parameter.
So the suggestion, actually,
that goes to Fisher
was to organize the expansion as
a power series in this quantity
epsilon.
And eventually then, ask what
the properties of these series
are as a function of epsilon.
So then I have all those others.
I forgot, actually, to
write l, by dt by dl.
Well, compared to k, it
has two additional factor
of gradients, which means that
it will start with minus 2l.
And then we said that
it will get corrections
that are of the
order of u squared,
and uv, and such things.
dv by dl.
I mean, compared to this
term, compared to u,
it has two more gradients
in the construction.
So it's dimension will
be minus 2 plus epsilon.
And then we'll get directions
of the order of, presumably,
u squared, uv, [INAUDIBLE].
And then, what else did I write?
I wrote something
about d u6 by dl.
d u6 by dl, I have to substitute
for z 1 plus d over 2.
Subtract 5d.
Rewrite d as 4 minus epsilon.
Once you do that, you will
find that it becomes minus 2
plus 2 epsilon.
Let me just make sure that I
am not saying something wrong.
Yeah, u6 plus order
of uv and so forth.
So there is this whole
set of parameters
that are being changed as a
function of-- going away--
changing the rescaling
by a factor of b
is 1 plus an infinitesimal.
So this is the flow of
parameter in this space.
So then to confirm
the ideas of Kadanoff,
we have to find the fixed point.
And there is clearly
a fixed point
when all of these
parameters are 0.
If they are 0, nothing changes.
And I'm back to
the Gaussian model,
which is described
by just gradient of m
squared type of theory.
So this is the fixed
point that corresponds
to t star, u star, l star,
v star, all of the things
that I can think
of, are equal to 0.
It's a perfectly good fixed
point of the transformation.
It doesn't suit us
because it actually
has still two
relevant directions.
It's obvious that if I
make a small change in u,
then in dimensions less than
4, u is a relevant direction
and t is a relevant direction.
Two directions does not describe
the physics that I want.
But there is fortunately
another fixed point,
the one that we call the
O n fixed point because it
explicitly depends
on the parameter n.
And what I need to do is
to set this equal to 0.
And if I set that equal
to 0, what do I get?
I get u star just
manipulating this.
It is proportional to epsilon.
1u drops out.
It is proportional to
epsilon The coefficient has
a factor of 1 over 4 n plus 8.
Basically, the inverse of this.
And then also, the
inverse of all of that.
So I have t star plus k lambda
squared and so forth squared
divided by kd lambda to the d.
Then, what I need to do is to
set the second equation to 0.
You can see that
this is a term that
is order of epsilon squared now.
Whereas, this is a term
that is order of epsilon.
So for calculating the
position of the fixed point,
I don't need this parameter.
And what do I get?
I will get that t star is minus
2 n plus 2 kd lambda to the d
divided by t star plus k
lambda squared and so forth.
Times u star.
u star is epsilon 4 n plus
8 t star plus k lambda
squared and so forth squared.
Divided by kd lambda to the d.
Again, I'm calculating
everything correctly
to order of epsilon.
So since t star is
order of epsilon,
I can drop it over here.
So my u star is, in fact,
epsilon divided by 4 n plus 8.
And then this
combination k lambda
squared and so forth squared
divided by kd lambda to the d.
And doing the same
thing up here,
my t star is epsilon n plus
2 divided by 2 n plus 8.
It has an overall minus sign.
The kd parts cancel.
And one of these
factors cancel, so I
will get k lambda
squared squared.
Sorry, no square here.
And both of these
will get corrections
that are order of
epsilon squared
that I haven't calculated.
Now, let's make sure that
it was justified for me
to focus on these two parameters
and look at everything else
as being not important before.
Well, look at these equations.
This equation says that
if I had a term that
was order of u squared
evaluated at a fixed point,
it would be epsilon squared.
So l star would be of the
order of epsilon squared.
You can check that
v star would be
of the order of epsilon squared.
A lot of those things will be
v star.
And actually, if you
look at it carefully,
you'll find that things
like u6 will be even worse.
They would start at order of
epsilon cubed and so forth.
So quite systematically in this
small parameter that Fisher
introduced, we see that what has
happened is that we have a huge
set of parameters, these mu's.
But we can focus
on the projection
in the parameter space t and u.
And in that parameter
space, we certainly always
have the Gaussian fixed point.
But as long as I am in
dimensions less than 4,
the Gaussian fixed
point is not only
relevant in the t-direction
by a factor of 2,
but it also is relevant
in another direction.
There is an eigen-direction
that is slightly shifted
with respect to t equals to 0.
It's not just the u-axis.
Along that direction,
it moves away.
Here you have an
eigenvalue of 2.
eigenvalue of epsilon.
So that's the
Gaussian fixed point.
But now we found
another fixed point,
which is occurring
for some positive u
star and some negative u star.
This is the o n fixed point.
Kind of just by
the continuity, you
would expect that if
things are going into here,
it probably makes sense that
it should be going like here
and this should be a
negative eigenvalue.
But one can
explicitly check that.
So basically, the
procedure to check that
is to do what I told you.
I have to construct a
linearized matrix that
relates delta mu going
away from this fixed point
to what happens under rescaling.
So basically, under rescaling
I will find that if I set my mu
to be mu star plus a
small change delta mu,
then it will be moving away.
And I can look at how,
let's say, delta t changes,
how delta u changes,
how delta l changes,
the whole list of parameters
that I have over here.
The linearized matrix
will relate them
to the vector that
corresponds to delta t,
delta u, blah, blah.
So I have to go back to
these recursion relations,
make small changes in
all of the parameters,
linearize the result,
construct that matrix,
and then evaluate the
eigenvalues of that matrix.
Again, consistency to the
order that I have done things.
And for example, one of the
things that we saw last time
is that there will
be an element here
that corresponds
to the change in u
if I make a change in delta t.
There is such a contribution.
If I make a change delta t with
respect to the fixed point,
I will get a
derivative from here.
But that derivative
multiplies u squared.
Evaluated at the
fixed point means
that I will get a
term down here that
is order of epsilon squared.
And then the second
element here,
what happens if I
make a change in u?
Well, I will get a epsilon here.
And then I get a
subtraction from here.
And this subtraction
we evaluated last time
and it turned out to be
epsilon minus 2 epsilon.
So the relevance
that we had over here
became an irrelevance
that I wanted.
So there is some matrix
element in this corner.
But since this is 0, as we
discussed if I look at this 2
by 2 block, it doesn't
affect this eigenvalue.
Since I did not evaluate
this eigenvalue last time,
I'll do it now.
So in order to
calculate the yt, what
I need to do is to
see what happens
if I change t to t plus delta t.
So I have to take a
derivative with respect to t.
From the first
one, I will get 2.
From the second term, I will
get minus 4 u n plus 2 kd
lambda to the d-- what is
in the denominator squared.
So t plus k lambda squared
and so forth squared.
But I have to evaluate
this at the fixed point.
So I put a u star here.
I put a u star here.
Since u star is already
order of epsilon,
this order of epsilon
term I can ignore.
And so what I have here is 2
minus 4 n plus 2 epsi-- OK.
Now, let's put u star.
u star I have up here.
It is epsilon divided
by 4 n plus 8.
I have k lambda squared
and so forth squared.
kd lambda to the d.
So I substituted the u star.
I had the n plus 2.
So now I have the
kd lambda to the d.
And I have this
whole thing squared.
And you see that all of
these things cancel out.
And the answer is
simply 2 minus n
plus 2 epsilon
divided by n plus 8.
And somehow, I feel that
I made a factor of-- no,
I think that's fine.
Double check.
Yep.
All right.
So let's see what happened.
We have identified two
fixed points, Gaussian
and in dimensions
less than 4, the O n.
Associated with
this are a number
of operators that tell me-- or
eigen-directions that tell me
if I go away from the fixed
point, whether I would go back
or I would go away.
And so for the
Gaussian, these just
have the names of the parameters
that we have to set non-zero.
So their names are things like
t, u, l, v, u6, and so forth.
And the value of these
exponents we can actually
get without doing anything
because what is happening here
is just dimensional analysis.
So if I simply replace
m by something,
m prime, gradients or
integrations with some power
of distance b, I can
very easily figure out
what the dimensions of
these quantities are.
They are 2, epsilon, minus 2,
minus 2 plus epsilon, minus 2
plus 2 epsilon, and so forth.
So this is simple
dimensional analysis.
And in some sense, these
correspond to their dimensions
of the theory of the
variables that you have.
Problem with it as a description
of what I see in experiments
is the presence of two
relevant directions.
Now, we found a new
fixed point that
is under control to
order of epsilon.
And what we find is
that this exponent
for what was analogous to t
shifted to be 2 minus n plus 2
over n plus 8 epsilon.
While the one that was
epsilon shifted by minus 2
epsilon and became
minus epsilon.
What I see is a pattern
that essentially all that
can happen, since I'm doing
a perturbation in epsilon,
is that these quantities
can at most change
by order of epsilon.
So this was minus 2 becomes
minus 2 plus order of epsilon.
This becomes minus 2
plus order of epsilon.
It will not necessarily
be minus 2 plus epsilon.
It could be minus 2 minus
7 epsilon plus 11 epsilon.
Maybe even epsilon
squared, I don't know.
But the point is
that clearly, even
if I put all the
infinity of parameters,
as long as I am in 3.999
dimension, at this fixed point
I only have one
relevant direction.
So it does describe the
physics that I want, at least
in this perturbative sense
of the epsilon expansion.
And so I have my yt.
Actually, in order to
get all of the exponents,
I really need two.
I need yt and maybe yh.
But yh is very simple.
If I were to add to this
magnetic field term,
then in Fourier representation
it just goes and sits over here
at q equals to 0.
And when I do all
of my rescalings,
et cetera, the only
thing that happens to it
is that it just picks
the factor of z.
And we've shown that z is
b to the 1 plus d over 2
plus order of epsilon squared.
And so essentially,
we also have our yh.
So I can even add
it to this table.
There is a yh.
There is a magnetic field.
The corresponding yh is 1 plus
d over 2 for the Gaussian.
It is 1 plus d over 2 plus order
of epsilon squared for the O n
model.
So now we have
everything that we need.
We can compute
things in principle.
We find, first of
all, that if I look
at the divergence of the
correlation length, essentially
we saw that under
rescaling yt tells us
that if our magnetic field
is 0, how I get thrown away
from the fixed point over here.
There is a relevant
direction out here
that we've discovered whose
eigenvalue here is no longer 2.
It is 2 minus this formula
that we've calculated.
And presumably again,
if I go and look
at my set of parameters,
what I have is that
in this infinite dimensional
space, as I reduce temperature,
I will be going from,
say, one point here,
then lower temperature
would be here,
lower temperature would be here.
So there would be a trajectory
as a function of shifting
temperature, which at some
point that trajectory hits
the basin of attraction of this
O n fixed point that we found.
And then being
away from here will
have a projection
along this axis.
And we can relate that to
the divergence of, say,
the correlation length
to the free energy.
Our u was 1 over yt.
It is the inverse
of this object.
So let's say this
is-- if I divide,
I have 1/2 1 minus
n plus 2 over 2 n
plus 8 epsilon raised
to the minus 1 power.
And to be consistent, I
should really only expand this
to the order of epsilon.
So I have 1/2 plus 1/4 n
plus 2 n plus 8 epsilon.
So what does it tell me?
Well, it tells me that
Gaussian fixed point,
the correlation length
exponent was 1/2.
We already saw that.
We see that when we
go to this O n model,
the correlation length exponent
becomes larger than 1/2.
I guess that agrees
with our table.
And I guess we can
try to estimate
what values we would get if
we were to put n equals to 1,
n equals to 2, et cetera.
So this is n equals to 1.
If I put epsilon equals to
1, what do I get for mu?
I will get 1/2 plus 1/4 of 3/9.
So that's 1/12.
So that would give me
something like 0.58.
All right.
Not bad for a
low-order expansion
coming from 4 to something
that's in three dimensions.
What happens if I
go to n equals to 2?
OK, so correction is
4/10 divided by 4.
So it's 0.1.
So I would get 0.6.
What happens if I
put n equals to 3?
I will get 5 divided by 44.
And I believe that gives
me something like 61.
So it gets worse when I
go to larger values of n,
but it does capture a trend.
Experimentally, we
see that mu becomes
larger as you go from 1 to 2
or 3-component order parameter.
That trend is already captured
by this low-order expansion.
Once you have mu, you can,
for example, calculate alpha.
Alpha is 2 minus d mu.
So you do 2 minus your
d is 4 minus epsilon.
Your mu is this 1/2 1 plus
1/8 n plus 2 n plus 8 epsilon.
1/2, sorry.
And you do the algebra
and I'll write the answer.
It is 4 minus n epsilon
divided by 2 n plus 8.
OK, and let me check.
So if I now substitute
epsilon equals
to 1 for these different
values of n, what I get
are for alpha 0.17, 0.11, 0.06.
I don't know, maybe I have
a factor of 2 missing,
or whatever.
But these numbers, I
think, are correct.
So you can see that in
reality alpha is positive
for the liquid gas
system n equals to 1.
It is more or less 0.
This is the logarithmic
lambda point for superfluids.
And then it becomes negative,
clearly, for magnets.
The formula that we have
predicts all of these numbers
to be positive, but it
gets the right trend
that as you go to
larger values of n,
the value of the
exponent alpha calculated
at this order in epsilon
expansion becomes lower.
So that trend is captured.
So at this stage,
I guess I would
say that the
problem that I posed
is solved in the same
sense that I would
say we have solved for the
energy levels of the helium
atom.
Certainly, you can sort
of ignore the interaction
between electrons and
calculate hydrogenic energies.
And then you can do
perturbation in the strength
of the interaction and
get corrections to that.
So essentially, you know the
trends and you know everything.
And we have been
able to sort of find
the physical structure
that would give us
a root to calculating
what these exponents are.
We see that the
exponents are really
a function of dimensionality
and the symmetry of the order
parameter.
All of the trends are captured,
but the numerical values,
not surprisingly,
at this low order
have not been
captured very well.
So presumably, you would
need to do the same thing
that you would do
for the helium atom.
You could do to higher and
higher order calculations.
You could do simulations.
You could do all
kinds of other things.
But the conceptual
foundation is basically
what we have laid out here.
OK, there is one thing
that-- well, many things that
remain to be answered.
One of them is--
well, how do you
know that there isn't a
fixed point somewhere else?
You calculated things
perturbatively.
The answer is that once you
do higher-order calculations,
et cetera, you find that
your results converge,
more or less, better and better
to the results of simulations
or experiments, et cetera.
So there is no
evidence from whatever
we know that there
is need for something
that I would call
a strong coupling,
non-perturbative fixed point.
It's not a proof.
We can't prove that
there isn't such a thing.
But there is apparently
no need for such a thing
to discuss what is
observed experimentally.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You told us last time
that in order for the mu fixed
point to make sense, we must
have epsilon very small.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But now we're
putting epsilon back to 1.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So when people inevitably
ask me this question,
I give them the following
two functions of epsilon.
One of them is e to
the epsilon over 100
and the other is e
to the 100 epsilon.
Do I know if I put epsilon
of 1 a priori whether or not
putting epsilon equals to 1 is
a good thing for the expansion
or not?
I don't.
And so I don't know
whether it is bad
and I don't know
whether it is good,
unless I calculate many
more terms in the series
and discuss what the
convergence of the series is.
AUDIENCE: Epsilon is 4 minus d
is supposed to be an integer.
We just--
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're worried
about its integerness as
opposed to treating
it as a continuum?
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's OK when you
first assume it [INAUDIBLE].
At the end of the day,
it must be an integer.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the example somebody was
asking me also last time
that I have in mind is
you've learned n factorial
to be the product of 1, 2, 3, 4.
And you know it for whatever
integer that you would like,
you do the multiplication.
But we've also established that
n factorial is an integral 0
to infinity dx x to
the n e to the minus x.
And so the question
is now, can I
talk about 4.111
factorial or not?
Can I expand 4.11
factorial close
to what I have 4 assuming the
form of this so-called gamma
function?
So the gamma function
is a function of n
that at integer values it
falls on whatever we know,
but it has a perfect
analytic continuation
and I can in principle evaluate
4 factorial by expanding
around 3 and the derivatives
of the gamma function
evaluated at 3.
AUDIENCE: But these
kind of integers
don't have anything
with dimensionality.
PROFESSOR: OK, where did our
dimensionality come from?
Our dimensionality
appears in our expressions
because we have to do
integrals of this form.
And what do we do?
We replace this with a
surface area, which actually
involves the
factorial by the way.
And then we have k
to the d minus 1 dk.
So these integrals are
functions of dimension
that have exactly the same
properties as the gamma
function and the n factorial.
They're perfectly
well expandable.
And they do have singularities.
Actually, it turns out
the gamma functions also
have singularities at
minus 1, things like that.
Our functions have singularities
at two dimensions and so forth.
But the issue of convergence
is very important.
So let's say that there were
some powerful field theories.
And in order to do
calculations at higher orders,
you need to go and
do field theory.
And you calculate
the exponent gamma.
And I will write the gamma
exponent for the case of n
equals to 1.
And the series for that is 1
plus-- if we sort of go and do
all of our calculations to
lowest order, gamma is 2 mu.
So it will simply be twice
what we have over here.
And the first correction is,
indeed, 167 times epsilon.
The next one is 0.077
epsilon squared.
The next one is
minus-- problematic--
049 epsilon cubed.
Next one, 180 epsilon
to the fourth.
Next one-- and I think
this is as far as people
have calculated things--
epsilon to the fifth.
Then, let's put
epsilon equals to 1
and see what we get
at the various orders.
So clearly, I start with 1.
Next order I will get 1.167.
At the next order,
I will get 1.244.
It's getting there, huh?
And the next order
I will get 1.195.
Then I will get 1.375.
And then I will get 0.96.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is the signature of what
is called an asymptotic series,
something that as you evaluate
more therms gets closer
to the expected
result, but then starts
to move away and oscillate.
Yet, there are tricks.
And if you know your tricks,
you can put epsilon equals to 1
in that series and do
clever enough terms
to get 1.2385 minus plus 0.0025.
So the trick is called
Borel summation.
So one can show that if you go
to high orders in this series,
asymptotically the terms in
the series scale like, say,
the p-th term in the series will
scale as p factorial, something
like a to the power of p and
some coefficient in front.
So if I write the general
term in this series
f sub p epsilon to
the p, my statement
is that the magnitude of f sub
p asymptotically for p much
larger than 1 going to
infinity has this form.
So clearly, because
of this p factorial,
this is growing too rapidly.
But what you can do is you
can rewrite this series, which
is sum over p f of p epsilon
of p using this integral that I
had over here for p factorial.
So I multiply and
divide by p factorial.
So it becomes a sum over p f
of p epsilon of p integral 0
to infinity dx x to
the p e to the minus x
divided by p factorial.
And the fp over p factorial
gets rid of this factor.
So then you can recast
this as the integral
from 0 to infinity
dx e to the minus x.
And what you do is you sum
the series f of p divided by p
factorial epsilon x
raised to the power of p.
And it turns out that this is
called some kind of a Borel
function corresponding
to this series.
And as long as the terms in your
series only diverge this badly,
people can make sense of this
function, Borel function.
And then you perform
the integration,
and then you come
up with this number.
So that's one thing to note.
The other thing
to note is I said
that what I want to do
for my perturbation theory
to make sense is for
this u star to be small.
And I said that the
knob that we have
is for epsilon to be small.
But there is, if you look at
that expression, another knob.
I can make n going to infinity.
So if n becomes very
large-- so that also
can make the thing small.
So there is an
alternative expansion.
Rather than going with
epsilon going to 0,
you go to what is called
a spherical model.
That is, an infinite
number of components,
and then do in
expansion in 1 over n.
And so then you
basically-- what you
are interested is things
that are happening
as a function of d and n.
And you have-- above
4, you know that you
are in the Gaussian world.
At n goes to infinity, you
have this O n type of models.
And you find that these models
actually only make sense
in dimensions that
are larger than 2.
So you can then perturbatively
come either from here
or you can come from
here and you try to get
to the exponents you
are interested over here
or over here.
So basically, that's the story.
And for this work,
I think, as I said,
Wilson did this pertubative RG.
Michael Fisher
was the person who
focused it into an
epsilon expansion.
And in 1982, Wilson got the
Nobel Prize for the work.
Potentially, it
could have been also
awarded to Fisher and Kadanoff
for their contributions
to this whole story.
So that's the end of
this part of the course.
And now that we have
established this background,
we will try to get the exponents
and the statistical behavior
by a number of
other perspectives.
So basically, this
was a perspective
and a route that gave an answer.
And hopefully, we'll be
able to complement it
with other ways of
looking at the story.